a very good evening i just want to bring
you some
breaking news uh following on uh from
that announcement regarding uh
the airline of belarus well grant shaps
the transport secretary has tweeted
in the last few moments let's take a
look at exactly
what he has said he said following
yesterday's removal
of permission for bellavia to operate
to from the uk i'm now taking
further action with immediate effect
bella russian airlines will be prevented
from
entering uk airspace unless specifically
authorized so that news coming in the
last couple of minutes
or so it all comes as boris johnson
warns that the actions of belarus
will have consequences so we saw that
video emerged last night of the detained
journalist
roman protosevich appearing to admit
organizing anti-government protests that
was while he was in jail of course
in minsk that he made that video boris
johnson
uh issuing his warning after mr
produceevich's father
said that his son's appearance in that
video had only occurred as a result
of coercion so we're now getting that
update from grant
shaps on twitter uh telling us that
uh from a media with a immediate effect
better russian airlines will be
prevented from entering uk airspace
unless specifically authorized